by the way I wanted what I let's just do
there let's talk about the elephant
there
I loved your comment back to us just so
you know I want you to know that that
didn't bother me at all
in fact I loved it because it was very
honest of you yeah I could see you were
frustrated and it hurt and you're a
little mad and you put up a little wall
and you told us what you thought yeah
and I I I liked it yeah because that's I
know you're strong mm-hmm I know you've
got emotions yeah and that's what I want
to tap into you so well the last time I
showed emotion is at the Olympics and I
got a bronze instead of gold
why did you show motion that time
because I was feeling confident like the
hard parts of my team is over I've been
doing this scale for like eight years of
my life you let loose for a minute yes
and it cost you yes keep what makes you
so fantastic your discipline your
precision your incredible athleticism I
just want you to know that dancing is
not gymnastics so for the judges
challenge I have chosen a jive for you
because jive is athletic and it's I
think in your wheelhouse for what I want
to see on top of that is emotional depth
well that's a little story to me you
need to let loose just like I know I I'm
gonna do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]